when you're also depressed too like I
think you forget how dirty and smelly
and you skip showers and you might just
be doing hella drugs what a life that
was just eating Taco Bell jacking off
into the same [__] rapper that you
just finished eating in and then like
that's despair
[Music]
welcome back to another freaking awesome
episode of the careful boys where we
have Jimmy Zhang in the building today
Joe take it away what were you gonna ask
him
okay you know what I like about you
Jimmy
um
let me tell you something okay so in the
world of Asian America
uh people that make contact don't do so
hard
um now you're not very Asian focused but
you do help
Asian peoples Asian males and all that
specifically not just Asians though you
help guys with having confidence dating
and all that and what I like about your
story is you're not um
you're not ashamed to talk about what a
loser you were man not even I don't even
mean it like that it's very honest it's
it's like I think a lot of people when
they get on camera they want to pretend
that they never were shy they never I've
always been [__] confident I've
always been getting girls you know and
then in your in your videos it's like
you're reaching out to like who you used
to be and people see that content and
then they're like you know what
I think I'm gonna try to like go on a
date with a porn star now like you
really push them not that far but
they could dream they could
but like at least maybe talk to people
make friends go out there and that I
love that message about you because it's
like
there's a whole group of I think
within creators in the Asian Circle some
are more like
um they're kind of victims you know what
I mean like their philosophy is much
more different from ours and it's been a
long time where I thought about like
just asian-ness but since you're here
and you kind of reminded me of that I'm
like
um do you have a lot of fans that are
specifically Asian male kids that are
like hey man you help me get [__] not
even that but just become become like
that's jokes but like become more open
and confident and all those traits that
you wish you had and do you know kind of
like your demographic in terms of like
which people you end up like is there a
pattern of people that you're kind of
helping a little bit more than others or
anything like that yeah I think um
Beyond just the asianist because I like
I made a lot of videos about anime uh
that is I I just tapped into the entire
nerd community in general right and and
that was like a big part of my audience
and when I go to these Anime conventions
it's it's not just Asian people coming
up to me it's it's black kids white kids
all ethnicity like anime is just a big
um so I I don't think it's just
uh that the Asian kids coming up and I'm
not just I'm I feel like I'm helping out
just like the nerd Community a little
bit
um there's no race on nerd
um it's just that a lot of the Nerds are
Asian
you're right like that
um I think beyond the the asianness
though it's just like
it like be before uh we started rolling
we were talking about uh
you know just being being a victim or
just like getting girls outside of you
you know like not being able to get
girls out of your circle or or anything
like that
um and I I see my little brother as like
a huge example of it he does it he just
is he just hangs out with with people
and then I guess
the people that he hangs out with
ends up being like his like reality like
he hangs out with a lot of white kids so
naturally
he he dated a white girl yeah right so
you're kind of a product of your
environment so is he in a you said he
was in a sports or something right he he
he's on the varsity basketball Varsity
stud so that makes sense because like
traditionally athletes in high school
will date the cheerleader the popular
girl jocks right right so like he's a
jock Circle it just so happens that
maybe that school had a lot of white
kids sure and jobs are anti-nerd but
then but then
what I'm talking about is like I think
you're 100 right like you you gravitate
toward the people that you like right
but like I'm talking about a group who
will look at race first or ethnicity
first and not even take into
consideration like and say like well
maybe I'm not into surfing but I'm
trying to get a skater girl or like a
surfer girl it's like you're not even
into the same [__] right right but then
but then but then they they look at it
as a Asian thing or whatever right oh
it's because I'm Asian I can't get yes
I've heard this so many times and I
think that's kind of like the whole
thing we were kind of what do you have
like what's your advice or suggestion to
people that have that mindset well I
think okay okay I'm
a question uh
so naturally just statistically right if
you go on these dating apps I guess you
could say like Asians Asian guys are on
the low special according to Nick dude I
didn't say that oh well this is your
yeah that's your thing yeah of getting
matched but um I think
it's yeah it's it's a victim mentality
you're you're kind of trapping yourself
like what you tell you the stories that
you tell yourself is becomes your actual
reality right so just being aware of
that idea like why would you trap
yourself
in that box
right it just doesn't makes like if you
had the choice of getting a whole world
of women why don't you just choose to
like hey I could get a whole world of
women
right and I think people just see these
statistics see certain stories and they
just box themselves right so I think one
is is it's like mentality second is is
the self-improvement right like maybe
like you are like maybe you you just
have the biggest ego you you have the
the biggest blind confidence and you're
just going up to the baddest [__] but
you weigh like 300 pounds right and and
you're you're shooting blanks right then
you know you gotta self-assess a little
bit huh maybe I should lose some weight
what are what are some attractive things
uh that I could do to better myself so
you just work on those things yeah so
it's it's it's it's it's mindset in
combination with self-awareness
self-awareness and self-improvement and
just with those things you could do
anything in life did you were you ever
like either in that box or like I was I
was I I think I think for you once had a
mentality like I can't get a girl
outside yeah yeah yeah what broke you
out because what I've noticed is people
that are in that mentality
they end up creating more theories that
back up their claims so if they go oh
girls don't like me because I'm Asian
and statistically a lot of you know
Asians Asian men are not on in theater
they're not looked upon as attractive
whatever whatever and then they might
stack on but also
um I'm five six so I'm not six feet but
also I'm this I'm that and then like
they start stacking up evidence of
why but on the flip side you you could
also Stack Up evidence that that that
dispute that you see Tim right he's five
five five yeah four you know he exactly
yeah but he's got brown eyes and a smile
like the sunrise you know what I'm
saying so that's true so for in your
case what broke you out of that like
world where you're where you're where
you felt like that and then you go but
wait there's there's this part too right
so I think it's a combination of of
people who I was surrounding myself with
at that time right the people that I was
with that at that time was also all
self-deprecating talking about like oh I
can't get girls either I can get so I
feel like a lot of people who says those
kind of things they're surrounded by
people that also say those type of
things also believe in those type of
things uh and that's why they probably
bought they have a shared sense of like
camaraderie about that and a shared
sense of Despair and depression right
but I think when I was reading those
books I I started becoming aware of like
how powerful your thoughts are to
shaping like your reality so I cut those
friends off stop yeah yeah because it
wasn't that hard a lot of people feel
very attached to their friends like how
are you able to just well you know what
I need to like separate myself because I
realized how detrimental they were to my
life at that point right I'm at that
point I was like 20 years old I still
haven't [__]
[__] did you try to tell them like hey
guys maybe we shouldn't be thinking this
way or like maybe we should see it this
way or like did you ever try to change
the conversation or anything I I think I
did but it was just so just depressing
and and they were just so like nah I
can't do it did it sound like you were
at an Asian film festival
I've never been that's a deep cut
did it feel like you were in the midst
of a next shark comment
one more
oh not too familiar with with those
comments but um
well this is kind of like what you were
saying even earlier even on things like
um your career and stuff and your
parenting and the way that they were you
know they were raising you and then you
read something like Rich Dad Poor Dad
and you're like wait a minute my parents
were like this but other parents are
like that and it changed your mindset
right so you know like I I can
understand how you you are self-aware
enough to recognize your Social Circle
and acknowledge something about that was
detrimental and then therefore making a
decision that would be an improvement to
your life but like like what are people
asking you when they're asking you for
help or advice like what are their
questions
um okay wait before I answer that there
was another thought I had about shark
yeah it's just a lot of times people are
are so afraid to change people are so uh
like it takes a it took a lot of work
for me to like break out of that circle
cut my friends off started going to the
like the skinny little kid bringing
myself to the gym with all these big
[__] that like already know how
to live and
right and then taking my ass to to like
uh like an improv class acting class
yeah it like all these things are just
insanely uncomfortable
for a guy like me back then like people
that are having those conversations like
of being a victim they they can't do
that that they're they're scared to do
it's a lot of work to be able to like
really change the the trajectory of
their life yeah you can't really change
until you switch from the victim to okay
I'm gonna own my life now and then you
start changing it versus life keeps
happening to me and then I have no
control right right oh that makes a lot
of sense because
I would like more reasons
and justifications why I see the world
this way like if I feel like I'm getting
the [__] kicked out of me and it's just
hopeless I want more evidence as why
it's hopeless it's comfortable so then
if someone tells me like hey the reason
why you're not dating is because like
oh they just don't like Asian guys or
whatever and then if if that was backed
up with some kind of Statistics I would
easily believe that if I was already
down right because that gives me an
answer like oh it's not me yeah it's
just out of my control yeah it's just
facts then I'm like oh I for because
when you're also depressed too like I
think you forget how dirty and smelly
and you skip showers and you might just
be doing hella drugs not for real dude
like I remember going days without
showering sometimes and just [__]
smoking weed every day what a life that
was right yeah and then you're just like
days would go by stable yeah just
[__] eating Taco Bell jacking off
into the same [__] rapper that you
just finished eating in and then like
that's despair that's the spare bro but
it goes back to what you were saying you
tried a nut on the cheese the little
cheese because you were saying that you
know it takes effort to go to improv
class it takes effort oh dude massive
yeah it's way easier just to be like
yeah nobody likes me right it's it's
every
yeah yeah it's not even just like Harder
by just you know um
strenuous it's like mentally hard it's
scary yes scary it's scary yeah
so so back to my other question what are
like how are fans reaching out to you
and then like what are questions they're
asking
so in terms of like help and advice I I
think I think the biggest question I get
is just is confidence
um like what do they say like how do you
have confidence or how do you get
confidence right right how do you be
more confident right and I think
confidence it's uh it's it's it's a lot
of factors that mold into confidence
right there's there there's that was
very that's a baby arm dude yeah bigger
than a baby on a Mac um
and I was like that's inappropriate yeah
sorry continue no no
have you thought about what makes what
are all those elements that make a
confidence uh yeah it's so there's like
different branches right it's like one
branch is like
lifting right being physically stronger
looking at yourself and just like wow
look at these muscles
along the same line there's like posture
there's like body language right
keep going
and then
um
dude stolen guys
uh this is how I flex confidence
[Laughter]
your bottom half is going crazy though
under the desk is going wild they can't
see the squats right yeah they can't see
the [__] gyrations now um and then
the other one would be like have to do
with your career right your uh career
financial success I guess
um like how well off are you on that
trajectory right like if if you're if
you have no job
it's hard to be yeah
um so that also could level up your
confidence and then there's like inner
confidence like things that you tell
yourself right confidence where you just
walk into the room and you're like Yeah
I'm I'm the [__] [__] you know so so
I love I love that one when you say like
you start going to the gym and you went
to improv that's already like from an
objective point of view I'm like dude
you might as well just give that advice
like how do I get my confidence go
[__] go to the gym and go to improv
class I was probably gonna like directly
help right right but like what was
something uh
like mental that you kind of like were
also kind of biohacking and tweaking for
yourself as well right it's those books
that I talked about it's like what are
some books that you recommend that you
read that you started reading because I
feel like it's a great way to Daniel
Steele [__] pick any of those yeah
you'll steal
um I think that the beginner ones are
like How to Win Friends and Influence
People Think and Grow Rich yeah
Dale Carnegie he's uh and then we have
books about uh
yeah but I don't like Malcolm Gladwell
no more [__] that fool dude talk some
[__] I used to really like that fool but
I was recently saw him on a [__] the
monkey debates you know the monkey
debates he did that he recently did one
about
um traditional media and new like new
news and [__] he's the guy who did the
tools of leadership one right or
whatever so as an author yeah it's chill
but when I saw the way that he debated
dude
[__] I wanted to slap the [__] [__]
out of him he was just a [__] dude he
was so mean but it's not about my
congratulations
oh another uh big influence and you guys
know this is Tony Robbins
um yeah yeah yeah Tony Robbins is cool
did you uh any of his courses I I went
to I went to his seminar which one uh I
went to the business Mastery and I went
to the uh the date with Destiny yeah no
no no no no the um Unleash the Power at
least Unleashed he actually um so the
biggest takeaway I had from that stuff
is uh my ability to control my anxiety
and
um feelings and noticing that I have
that anxiety boiling up and not letting
it turn into anger or anything else uh
through uh one of the methods he uses is
basically changing your state your
physical state so if you're like feeling
tense and tight and scared then it's
like you know what just [__] run up
and down the block real quick and see
how you feel yeah or like you might be
feeling like tense and like tired and
they're like well maybe you need to
drink a [__] bottle of water and do
some jumping jacks right quick play some
music you might feel like a like a nut
case but I'm like everyone already looks
at me as a nutcase so [__] it I play
some music I just start jumping jacking
and I'm like yo whatever I was stressing
about earlier and it's not suppression
all it is is he's like when you feel
stressed you'll think stressed when you
feel happy you'll think happy and then
so the decisions that you make based on
your state of mind right now will
basically be a reality right so let's
say someone passed away in your family
that you love dearly you're gonna have
negative thoughts so the way that you
try to solve an issue with that mind
State it's probably gonna be a negative
conclusion
about your relationship about your
friendship whatever and you're only
gonna have bad Solutions exactly coming
from that place because it's coming from
a place of scarcity you're afraid you're
you're you know all those things so you
might have negative thoughts and he goes
well if you want Positive Solutions and
conclusions then change your state and
I'm like oh [__] this is weird is it
that easy it can't be that easy and I
tried it and I'm like oh yeah it's
[__] easy it really is what uh made
you want to even take those courses
um I think for most people like because
I was kind of like I don't know about
these courses feels kind of like cultish
or whatever yeah yeah but then I'm like
oh I still did feel a little bit Yeah
Yeah but for me like because like I I
always feel like
it's weird to like have like a assistant
Jesus type of vibe like for anybody not
not just him but just somebody like
assistant Jesus I'm gonna go there and
[__] like I don't know he's gonna
like oh you're cured or whatever but
then I also go like but is that me like
me judging something that I haven't done
that's me being close-minded right so
you know I'm gonna go and I got a lot of
benefits from it for you
um what brought you there or what made
you even want to take like the leap of
faith to go into like a theme that could
be viewed as like a weird thing uh I
think
um it's the difference between when I
first read his book and like now I went
to his thing like about like a year and
a half ago and I think during that time
like my YouTube was really struggling uh
yeah I was uh I was getting like a
consistent like like 10 out of 10 like
rankings on on the videos so I was just
like [__] I like nothing's going right I
I feel like
um in a relationship that I felt kind of
constricted and entrapped it and then
um I just yeah I I wasn't too in too too
good and
thankfully I I went uh one of my boys
was was part of his like Platinum
program yeah so he he was like yo you
want to come with oh so he kind of took
me under his sister yeah
and so after that it kind of gave you a
new new kind of refreshed energy and
then you approach your channel much more
differently and now you're going on
dates with porn stars yeah that's cool
Tony Robbins yeah yeah no I'm glad was
the man yeah he's that guy I'm gonna go
see him so I can get something some
[__] yeah yeah Amber you're married
dude you can't say that anymore that's
what Joe said
I was just repeating him what are you
talking about allegedly
thank you